j'ai toujours été convaincu d'abord des
libertés de la détention même si ça a
été une décision très courageuse musique
j'y croyais voilà et puis devant la
chambre de l'instruction
je la connais c'est
il sombre
de l'instruction difficile pointilleuse
mais rigoureuse et respectueuse du droit
et donc j'avais confiance en fait ça va
quand même ça et à des violations
d'entorse en tout cas au contrôle
judiciaire de votre client mais vous
comprenez que entre une entorse qui n'a
aucune conséquence sur la manifestation
de la vérité est une violation du
contrôle judiciaire qui en a il ya un
monde d'écart je peux vous assurer que
connaissant la chambre de l'instruction
si aujourd'hui ça n'est constaté de
véritable violation de dupont fois
judiciaire du docteur peschier il ne
ressortait pas libre de l'audience de la
chambre de l'instruction
ça c'est une certitude ne sous-estimé
pas la célérité de la chambre de
l'instruction de besançon préjuge en
rien de ce qui va se passer mais le
maintien en liberté n'est pas un vrai
jugement donc se maintient en liberté
existe parce que dans le cas d'une
affaire compliquée où il n'y a pas de
preuves univoque sur la culpabilité du
docteur déchets il est bien évident que
la chambre de l'instruction se réfère
aux critères des garanties de
représentation et concernant ces
critères et en l'absence de
manifestations de rue en l'absence de
virer son du contrôle judiciaire il nous
semblait évident que la chambre de
l'instruction des maintenir le contrôle
judiciaire par contre on ne
sous-estiment pas le fait que toute la
campagne qu'il y a eu depuis trois
semaines dans la presse pour présenter
des éléments à charge contre le docteur
fraîchir sans avoir de contradiction en
défense on ne sous-estiment pas toutes
les rumeurs et la pression populaire qui
a pu la voir pour peser sur la chambre
de l'instruction et on ne sous-estimé
pas le courage des magistrats qui ont dû
faire ça c'est tout cela ont dû mettre
tout cela côté de se comporter
effectivement
comme des frères magistrats en gardien
des libertés individuelles c'est ce
qu'ont fait nos magistrats de la cour
d'appel de besançon comme notre juge des
libertés et de la détention
en même temps on peut penser que s'il y
avait eu des saignements sa charge en
crémant accablant votre finance
aujourd'hui placé en détention
je vais bien une chose très simple donc
si je suis votre voisin avec une arme à
feu et devant des témoins jeudi que la
preuve est évident que je serai placé en
détention provisoire
même si j'ai les meilleures garanties de
représentation du monde ça c'est une
évidence le dossier là je vous le dis je
vous le rappelle présomption d'innocence
il faut être scrupuleux là dessus j'ai
vu trop de journalistes disent grey
s'est jouée au petit procureur ou jouez
déjà aux tribunaux aux cours d'assises
ils n'ont pas les tenants et les
aboutissants de ce dossier c'est un
dossier technique et on parle de 24
carats et sur ses 24 cas on a toujours
dit nous ne reconnaissons qu'un
empoisonnement et pour le reste nous
parlons d'accidents alors la voie de la
défense n'est pas une voie subsidiaire
ce n'est pas toujours le procureur de la
république et à la vérité il peut se
tromper
la police judiciaire peut se tromper et
c'est ce que nous disons dans cette
affaire depuis deux ans et demi partant
client a pu s'exprimer aujourd'hui
i comme à ce qu'ils l'expliquent s'est
longtemps s'est interrogé dessus notre
client ne s'est quasiment pas exprimer
ce sont ses avocats qui se sont exprimés
le débat devant la chambre de
l'instruction est un débat dans lequel
les déclarations sont extrêmement rares
et assez peu d'importance dans le débat
comment at il accueilli sa décision
comme nous soulager voilà comme nous
soulager et puis je pense
qu'effectivement il se dit que
maintenant sa vie a changé
il sera plus jamais médecin il va
falloir peut-être aussi se changer
l'orientation et repenser sa vie
différemment mais c'est un homme qui
veut absolument démontrer autant qu'il
peut le faire
en collaborant avec la justice qui n'est
coupable de rien